Everyone's pretending they have it
together. Spoiler alert, they don't. You
know that constant buzzing feeling like
you should be doing something, but you
don't know what. That's your system
stuck in permanent alert mode. You're
not falling apart. You're having a
completely normal response to an
absolutely abnormal situation. I want to
show you something powerful. Draw a
circle. Inside it, put what you can
actually control. outside everything
else. We spend 90% of our energy on
things outside our circle, doom
scrolling, worrying, stressing about
things we literally cannot change.
Victor Frankle survived four
concentration camps. His main insight,
your ability to choose your response can
never be taken away. Remember this above
all else. You've survived every crisis
so far. Your track record for getting
through difficult days 100%.
The world might be falling apart, but
you you're becoming stronger through the
stress.